Hi everyone, my name is Sai Vennam with the IBM Cloud team.
Today the topic on everyone's mind: IBM and Red Hat.
Now our philosophy is straightforward:
Red Hat works, so let's keep it that way.
This includes preserving their independence,
their culture, as well as their commitment to open source.
Now we're in a very unique position here,
we're seeing rapid growth of applications being developed on the cloud
but that's linked with increasing complexity.
The next chapter of cloud computing is going to demand flexibility and choice.
That choice starts from the ground up
when choosing the environments to run or modernize your applications.
So, you can choose public or private clouds,
or even on-premise environments.
Building on that, we have the platform layer
which is supported by Red Hat's open source technologies.
So, we have Red Hat Enterprise Linux,
as well as OpenShift.
Now this is powered by open source technology, Kubernetes.
So, coming back to choice, if we wanted to use native Kubernete over OpenShift, that's also an option.
Building on that, we have the capabilities
layer.
This is what developers need to develop engaging new applications.
This would include things like databases,
maybe their favorite DevOps tool chains,
or even their middleware platforms.
So, for example,
we know that, for running J2EE applications,
developers may choose JBoss or WebSphere Liberty.
Regardless of whether or not you choose Red Hat or IBM technologies,
we will continue to support both fully as
we move forward.
Finally, all of this is channeling our users
to create new or engaging applications
by taking advantage of higher value services.
This is where IBM truly shines.
So, these include AI and machine learning capabilities.
To summarize, from the ground up we have a hybrid multicloud platform
where you can innovate anywhere.
We have open source technologies that Red Hat provides like OpenShift and Red Hat Enterprise Linux.
All together with their suite of technologies.
That, combined with IBM's commitment and expertise with enterprise
as well as our own suite of technologies,
is opening new doors to hybrid cloud that we've never seen before.
At the end of the day, it all comes down to an idea.
An idea that you build out into an application.
An application built on industry best practices that follow security guidelines and compliances.
Because we want the same thing that you do, and that is happy users.
Thanks for joining me for this quick overview of Red Hat and IBM synergy.
If you like this video, or have any comments, be sure to drop a "like" or comment below.
And if you want to see more videos like this in the future, please subscribe.
Thank you.